we're talking a little bit about science
and a little bit about philosophy as
well we're going to be having a chat
about intuition
so that's a great question and a really
hard question to answer to start with i
think that when philosophers talk about
intuitions
what they mean is something like a
seeming so something seems to be the
case it seems right you have that kind
of gut feeling or instinct
that something is the case
there was a really interesting book kind
of at the intersection between
philosophy of science and metaphysics
that came out in 2007 and particularly a
bit of it by a guy called james ladyman
and don ross focused on some claims
about intuitions and their use in
science and they said something which
was really interesting to me which was
that
scientists don't really use their
intuitions or at least if they do use
their intuitions they only use them in a
very very small range of cases uh now
this particularly struck me as something
that was interesting about this book
because as i said i was reading it was
very interesting lots of stuff going on
in there and they rely on a lot of data
in that book so when they're making
claims they give lots of sources make
lots of citations and you go okay great
so they've told me that scientists don't
use their intuitions when they're doing
science
and the citation is
and there wasn't one fine i'll go i'll
go away and find what they're talking
about i'll go and find the studies that
then show me that that scientists aren't
using their intuitions
and lo and behold i i couldn't find any
which was a little bit surprising to me
it seemed to me it was intuitive to me
that such studies would exist if they
were going to be saying that kind of
thing seems like a true thing like you
know there's no room for feelings in
science
right so your intuition is that
scientists don't use their intuitions
but our intuitions about empirical
matters maybe don't need to be trusted
quite so so strongly right so scientists
for a long time maybe had the intuition
that some people had the intuition that
quantum mechanics wasn't right it was
too strange it was too counterintuitive
because we now think that it is right so
so just saying we've got an intuition
that scientists don't use their
intuition doesn't look too compelling
so i did a survey of all the
publications over the last 10 years that
are put out by the american physical
society and this is an institution that
publishes a whole bunch of different
physics journals
and what i found was that over the last
10 years year on year between seven and
nine percent of all of the papers that
they're publishing actually mention the
word intuition or intuitive in various
different places how did you do this by
the way
if you go to their website you find that
all of their journals are searchable
so i did a keyword search for intuition
and intuitive across all of those
journals and then just map the number of
papers in total and came up with a
percentage they could be using that word
in a range of contexts i guess
absolutely and in fact it turns out they
are
um so there were some particularly
predominant categories of use that came
up when i dug down a little bit deeper
you say you find physicists saying
things like particular results were very
intuitive it was a result that felt
right okay it was a little bit
surprising to me one that i found
counter-intuitive shall we say but i'm a
philosopher right so i wouldn't
necessarily use the language in quite
the same way
other things that they described as
being intuitive were particular pictures
so they said that a particular way of
thinking about something gave rise to a
very intuitive picture of what's going
on
which was interesting
they also described particular theories
or explanations as being intuitive
in that context it sounds to me like
intuitive is just science speak for
as as i would expect or like in line
with previous results yeah and i think
in lots of the cases that that is what
that does seem to be the kind of way
that that it's being used so there's
that sense then that we had this
expectation
we got the sort of result that we were
expecting and that that seems right to
us
in some of the cases there did seem to
be what a little bit of a suggestion i
need to be a bit cautious here but but
in some of the cases people saying
we got this result that's intuitive so
so we think that's right and what
interested me was that last little bit
that maybe i'm guilty of reading in on
that first inspection it's that
so we think it's right okay so we have
this kind of feeling about this theory
or about this idea
and that we feel this way about it gives
us some reason to think that it's right
seems to be some particular cases where
scientists are saying
my gut feelings give me some reason to
think a theory is right or
some experiment has yielded the right
results there have been no errors here
or something like this
and that's giving intuition what we
might describe as an evidential role
it's saying that scientists intuitions
are actually a form of evidence about
whether or not
what they've done is correct and is
right
and that really really interested me
because
it's something that some philosophers
think gets done in philosophy we say
a particular theory is intuitive so it's
true
some people worry about that in
philosophy so if anything similar is
going on in science that's really really
interesting to me so the next step was
to go away and see if we could find
reasons to believe that might be what's
going on in the scientific case
is it a bit unfair on scientists to
refer to this as
gut feeling because if they're
experienced and have spent a lot of time
in science it's not like they've just
come off the street and they've been
absorbed with this feeling this is
something that is almost evidence-based
because they've used the machine a
thousand times or they've read a
thousand books so for them a gut feeling
is more than just a gut feeling isn't it
yeah i think that's right i think a gut
feeling for a scientist is more than
your gut feeling or my gut feeling i
think it does much more work than that
precisely because they're so experienced
they've spent so much time working with
the machinery with working with the
theories so anyway you've got where did
you go next you went and did a bit more
reading yeah so i've been trying to find
um
kind of social science studies
effectively of of whether or not
scientists claim to be using their
intuitions or gut feelings and if so how
um
so there's one really nice study that
came out in nature i think it was in
2004 or 2005.
and 3 000 scientists were asked
anonymously to confirm whether or not
they'd ever
dropped um there was a whole bunch of
questions but in particular whether or
not they'd ignored or dropped data
points from analyses or observations
from analyses on the basis of a gut
feeling
and 15 of them said that they had
okay so
very striking results we've got 15
percent of the scientists who respond to
this particular
uh anonymized survey saying yep there
are cases in which i've said that
doesn't look right to me that doesn't
feel right i'm going to ignore it okay
that seems like a big deal it seems like
a big deal it also and again to stress
seems perfectly reasonable no aspersions
being cast on the scientists here um but
yeah it does seem to be the case that
these intuitions these gut feelings are
then being used to weed out particular
results as ones that we just shouldn't
trust one thought might be when we get
down to it and this is a point that
ladyman and ross themselves make
the peer review process will effectively
serve to rid us of any intuitions that
are kind of getting weaseling their way
into into various different findings
that might be right okay it might it
might turn out to be right but i think
that there are some worries
about the peer review process
particularly as it happens in some
places in science where the peer review
isn't anonymized so the person doing the
review work knows the identity or knows
the names of
the people who have submitted the work
so there's one nice study uh or actually
quite troubling study that demonstrates
that when we anonymize the names of the
authors in a particular field in science
the proportion of papers that are
accepted by female authors rises quite
significantly
and so the worry is that there's a kind
of an unconscious bias
against women who are working in science
now
i don't want to suggest that anything
quite so bad is going on in in the case
of intuition use in science
but the thought is just that if uh if
that kind of unconscious bias can infect
reviewers
then one might also expect the
intuitions of that reviewer to play some
kind of role in determining whether or
not they're going to expect accept a
particular paper for publication
now i get the impression that you think
if intuition is
spreading throughout science that's
quite a good thing you think it could be
quite healthy
i'm not sure whether to say that the use
of intuitions in sciences is good or bad
healthy or unhealthy
what i'm really interested in is is
understanding how science works much
more cleanly than i think maybe we do at
the moment so there's this kind of
idealized sense of the scientific method
everything's very logic every every
logical totally um
dependent upon the evidence no room for
emotion or intuition to creep in there
and i there's that idealized version out
there and that's fine but what i'm
actually concerned with is how the
discipline as a whole itself evolves and
is so successful
now
maybe it turns out right maybe and much
more research needs to be done here
right but maybe what happens is the
reason that um those 15 of scientists
are dropping those data points is
because they've spent loads of time
working the machinery they're really
familiar with the theories they can just
tell that those are observations that we
don't need to pay any attention to
and so maybe what we need to do
is to get working with the other 85
percent of the scientists
train them in the use of their intuition
so that they can just drop data points
without
needing to perform more experiments they
can just see from their gut feelings
that those
observations were wrong they can use
their gut feelings as evidence in the
way these other guys are doing
i'm just totally neutral on the question
of whether or not this is a good thing
or a bad thing in science mostly because
i i worry that at the moment we really
don't understand what role intuitions
are playing
so we've got these these
very very able philosophers of science
james and don ross intuition just
doesn't get in anywhere in science
you do the kind of the analysis of the
papers you find lots of mentions of it
which is kind of some evidence that
something's going on
then you start to dig into this finding
in nature you read ethnographic studies
with nobel laureates who say yeah we use
intuitions in our work like a guiding
hand telling us where to go next
um and you start to think well actually
maybe there is something going on in
here that hasn't quite been articulated
and isn't quite fully understood
and i'm a philosopher right brady i like
to try and understand what's going on
and how it works and so that's where i
that's where i get really interested in
this but it's not absolutely not to say
intuition is good or intuition is bad
here
so would would perfect science be
science done without intuitions i don't
know so what i do know is that we have a
fantastically successful discipline
science a set of disciplines and that it
seems to make recourse to intuitions it
seems to me that intuitions
save time right but also possibly let
things slip through the neck that might
be right or it might be the case so so
come back to that um that that 15 of
scientists using their intuitions to or
gut feelings to drop data points from
analyses
we don't know who those 15 are
maybe those 15 are the ones who are
making the fantastic strides who are
field leaders who are
getting everything absolutely bang on
and right and maybe it's not just a time
saving device in there right maybe these
are the ones who don't know right we
just know how this needs to work and
we're going to
i don't know
so
it seems to me that you're probably
right and it's just being used as a
time-saving device and that
it's actually a problem in at least some
cases that this kind of thing's going on
well it's not a problem because these
people only have finite years on earth
and finite dollars in the bank so maybe
they're making their discoveries because
they save time right maybe they're
making a discoveries because they save
time their intuitions have helped them
to do that but maybe it's also leading
us into error in some cases because
we're dropping these points because
we're maybe even saying that some theory
is intuitive and so we're going to
believe that or adopt that or pursue
that
but
the point is we don't know what's going
on at the moment we might i mean each
each individual scientist will be able
to tell you what they think they do
um
when you put this question to them and
of course that that will change the
context slightly um are you using your
intuitions well i know i shouldn't be
right or at least maybe i believe i
shouldn't be so that'll change the
context of asking the question a little
bit but
what's actually going on on the mass
scale i think is something that's really
interesting maybe intuition helps maybe
it makes it worse
so some of my best friends are
scientists
i think that when i gave the talk uh to
the guys over in over in physics there
was
uh
quite a bit of skepticism about the
claims that intuitions are being having
an evidential role according to
mctaggart the a series is the series of
events running from future to present to
past
so we might say that the battle of
hastings was future then it became
present then it became past